it was albert brewer of si.com who once
upon a time was embedded with the
patriots wow with nfl network until he
asked bill belichick some questions
belichick didn't like then albert breer
was embedded with other teams
nowbriellewithsi.com reported earlier
this week that
the patriots had some trade
conversations regarding gilmore back in
march april and august and then breer
reported yesterday
that the patriots frankly like any other
team would listen to offers for almost
anyone on the roster belichick was asked
about the possibility that they will be
sellers as the trade deadline approaches
here's what belichick had to say
if you guys lose this weekend are you
automatic sellers at the trade deadline
i think that's what everybody's
wondering and kind of the talk radio
fodder and maybe it's not something you
entertain but that i think is is the
question
i guess i'll just put it nicely and and
pass on the opportunity to get involved
in talk radio it's really a
you know a tough one for me to
say no to but i'm just going to say no
to talk radio questions
thank you thanks for asking i appreciate
the opportunity to
get involved
sure does uh uh look always entertaining
and uh uh i'm sure that it's terrifying
to have to ask bill belichick questions
at least they're not there in person
that's the only saving grace this year
but
again
any team
would listen to offers for almost any
players we've talked about that this
week there's only a handful of guys who
are truly untouchable that you hang up
the phone or you start laughing
hysterically if someone calls and says
hey are you interested in trading
patrick mahomes so yeah they would
listen to offers for almost anyone of
course and if you offer enough
then you make the move that's just the
way it works
the difference this year is
they'd be more inclined to listen and
maybe more inclined to take less
because if they lose on sunday it could
be time to fold the tents on 2020 even
though there's that seventh seed that
they could get their act together and
and get to nine and seven and maybe
still get to the post-season train
yeah our good friend tom curran from
maybe sp c sports boston wrote a great
uh column on uh gilmore and says it's
not a matter of when it's i mean not
matter if it's a matter of when he's
going to be traded whether it's now at
the trade deadline or after the season
he doesn't expect gilmore to be back
with the patriots next season and he
does have one year left on his contract
but mike if i'm seattle in particular
and they're always in on top players but
32nd ranked defense in the nfl if i'm
particularly seattle but tennessee tampa
bay any of these teams that think they
have a chance to win the super bowl new
orleans whoever
i would make a call to patriots and i
would want to find gilmore on my team i
think he's still
if not the best cornerback in football
he's definitely in the top five and he
will improve whatever team he goes to so
it's not only about getting him on your
team to help your team but keeping him
off of one of these other contenders i
think he's going to end up with somebody
because i think somebody's going to make
a really good offer to the patriots that
they can't turn down and i do think
they're looking to trade him so it's
going to be an interesting next few days
i think for the patriots gilmore and see
who else
they have that they might ship out i
don't see a ton of players in that
roster that i would want i mean they had
eight opt-outs a lot of those guys you
might be talking about have opted out of
this season so i don't see a ton of
other players getting traded but i do
think there's a high possibility that
this guy is gone at some point the next
few days
we saw the lions get active the other
day trading for cowboys defensive end
everson griffin and if i were bill
belichick the lions are the team that i
would hope would call matt patricia
former defensive coordinator no stefan
gilmore bob quinn had been part of that
patriots cabal before he got the job so
there's a line of communication there
and i'd say the lions
of all those teams the most likely to
have the highest draft pick if it would
be a first rounder that you could get
for staphon gilmore so i would want the
lions first round pick over anyone
else's if i could choose and who knows
what the lions may be thinking along
those lines i was surprised they traded
for everything griffin but here they are
at three and three and if they would get
stefan gilmore
they do become serious contenders for
the seventh seed or the sixth seed in
the nfc so here's the thing that that
i've believed all week
wednesday thursday were the action days
for trades it doesn't mean they can't
happen but if you want the guy for week
nine
yesterday was the day to do it
if you wait until after sunday you're
not gonna have the guy for week nine now
for the bengals browns rams eagles
doesn't matter they don't play week nine
if they would be interested in a guy
like stefan gilmore for the other 27
teams you're not gonna have him for week
nine period and that may be okay and you
know the patriots and some of these
other teams shireen they may want to see
what happens this weekend before they
make final decisions that's always a
dynamic as we approach the trade
deadline the vikings for example if they
would somehow beat the packers and move
to two and five different vibe
altogether
than one and six so it may be one of
these things where let's see how it goes
sunday if the patriots win
maybe
they
keep stefan gilmore if they don't win
then maybe it's time to move on so i
agree with you though i think other
teams should be interested the question
is are you comfortable with the salary
next year and are you willing to give up
a first round pick to improve your
defense now
yes yes and yes
i want him on my team i'm willing to
give whatever it takes especially a team
like the bucks now i realize they don't
have the cap room probably to fit him
under maybe they can work it to to make
it work but you know a team like that
that's really all in for one year i'm
going all in for stephane gilmour i want
him on my team and i think he can help
make us a better team no matter who i
have at quarterback he's going to make
you better you never have too many
cornbreak so you look at what the
vikings are going through now with my
cues now on injury reserve and
everything else they're they're the top
three cornerbacks may be out on sunday
you just can never have enough good
cornerbacks and he's one of the best in
the business
and it wouldn't surprise me if the
buccaneers tried to pull something off
they've already pushed all their chips
into the middle of the table they've
thrown the watch onto the pile they've
thrown the keys onto the pipe you may as
well put the deed on there too what the
hell let's go get a super bowl win and
let's do it with stefan gilmore on top
of tom brady and rob gronkowski and
leonard fournette and lashawn mccoy and
most recently antonio brown
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports